When Neil Armstrong set his left boot on the
surface of the moon on July 21, 1969, becoming
the first person to ever walk on the moon.
He then spoke some of the most famous words
in the history of mankind, “That’s one
small step for man, one giant leap for mankind.”
So true, so brilliant, so inspirational yet…so
contradicting?
The word “man” and “mankind” are used
synonymously, meaning that the oh-so-famous
quote quite simply put was, “That’s one
small step for man, one giant leap for man.”
Huh?
A one-lettered indefinite article is all it
would take to turn this quote into the inspirational
words our brains all process when we hear
them.
That article is “a”- “One small step
for “a” man, one giant leap for mankind.”
That is how most people interpret his words
and, according to Neil Armstrong, those are
the words he intended to speak.
NASA’s official transcript of the quote
still shows the “a” in parentheses, “That’s
one small step for [a] man, one giant leap
for mankind.”
This is because the “a” is not audible
in the broadcast.
For years, both NASA and Armstrong insisted
that static had obscured the “a”.
Armstrong himself stated that he would never
make such a mistake (omitting such an important
part) but after listening to recordings of
his quote, finally conceded that it’s possible
that he may not have said the “a”.
When he admitted this, he stated, “I would
hope that history would grant me leeway for
dropping the syllable and understand that
it was certainly intended, even if it was
not said—although it might actually have
been”.
An Australia-based computer programmer named
Pater Shann Ford conducted a digital audio
analysis to support Armstrong’s claim that
he did say “a” and concluded that he did,
in fact, say “a man”, but the “a”
was inaudible due to technological limitations
of the time.
However, linguists David Beaver and Mark Liberman
wrote their own digital audio analysis of
the infamous quote on Language Log blog and
concluded that, “The acoustic evidence seems
to be against Ford’s theory.”
But that’s not the end of the story.
Support for Armstrong has been found in a
team of researchers from Michigan State University
and Ohio State University who have concluded
that Armstrong did indeed speak the words
he claims to have spoken but static or technological
limitations are not to blame for its apparent
omission.
According to them, Armstrong’s Ohion accent
is to blame y’all.
According to a Michigan State University specialist
in communicative sciences, assistant professor
Laura Diller, because of the dialect of his
hometown, if Neil Armstrong did voice the
word “a”, it was short and fully acoustically
blended with the preceding word “for”.
The Acoustical Society of America’s article
on this topic states that,
Dilley and her colleagues, who include MSU
linguist Melissa Baese-Berk and OSU psychologist
Mark Pitt, thought they might be able to figure
out what Armstrong said with a statistical
analysis of the duration of the ‘r’ sound
as spoken by native central Ohioans saying
‘for’ and ‘for a’ in natural conversation.
They used a collection of recordings of conversational
speech from 40 people raised in Columbus,
Ohio, near Armstrong’s native town of Wapakoneta.
Within this body of recordings, they found
191 cases of ‘for a’.
They matched each of these to an instance
of ‘for’ as said by the same speaker and
compared the relative duration.
They also examined the duration of Armstrong’s
‘for (a’) from the lunar transmission.
The researchers found a large overlap between
the relative duration of the ‘r’ sound
in ‘for’ and ‘for a’ using the Ohio
speech data.
The duration of the ‘frrr(uh)’ in Armstrong’s
recording was 0.127 seconds, which falls into
the middle of this overlap, though it is a
slightly better match for an ‘a’-less
‘for’.
In other words, the researchers conclude,
the lunar landing quote is highly compatible
with either possible interpretation, though
it is probably slightly more likely to be
perceived as ‘for’ regardless of what
Armstrong actually said.
Dilley says there may have been a ‘perfect
storm of conditions’ for the word ‘a’
to have been spoken but not heard.